HaloTalk is a platform
Connecting language learners from all over the world
Making language learning fun and attractive
Zachary Nagai, founder and executive director of HaloTalk
I was born in Hainan and grew up in Hong Kong
I also received my education in the United States
She worked in South Korea
Through my multicultural experiences
I created Halo Talk
I wish every learner a language
Be able to communicate with native language speakers
They are in real talks
Since its launch in 2013
HaloTook has been hugely popular among language learners
We have more than 12 million users around the world
Last year we won an award
Best Social Application in Google Playstation for 2017
It's a big challenge
To develop an instant chat program such as HaloTalk
Luckily
We have a console in Google Play to help improve the quality of the app
Android indicators aggregate and display data about application performance
This includes detailed analysis by device
Allowing rapid access to the optimum level of target devices
To help improve crash rates and user experience
With the help of android indicators
HaloTook managed to reduce the proportion of (the program does not respond) by 60%
And excessive alerts at 95%
HaloTook has built a stable business model with subscriptions
After adopting the Google Play model for subscriptions
We saw a 350% increase in revenues over the previous year
HaloTalk subscription renewal rate is around 75%
In case of automatic renewal failure
Give users seven days to fix payment issues
Which improved recovery from a 13%
Since we applied the introductory offer to sign up for Google Store
Our short-term income nearly quadrupled
HaloTook has been a global communication platform since the first day
Users can practice in more than 100 languages
With partners to learn from about 200 countries
We learned from the analytical data from the console in Google Play
That the continuation rates in Japan and South Korea
Much higher than the internal rate
This gives us a good reason to invest more to localize the application
For these two countries, from language to operations
The credit goes back to Google Play
Where HaloTook's rating is in the PlayStation
Rose from 3.7 to more than 4.3
Which strengthens our determination to create a better experience for our users
Through new technology
We sincerely hope it
In the future, everyone will be able to master at least three languages
While making new friendships in different countries
And enjoy the happiness
Provided by cultural diversity through HaloTook